ん
うんんんんんんんんんん
me
こういう時嫌な気持ちになるよね
こんにちははじめ社長です
っていう愛車つーかもう嫌になりました
いろんなユーチューバーありますね色んなユーチューバーいるんですけどもこうなんか
ね皆さん入った特徴できるんだこれが挨拶いろんな挨拶
相手はやっぱね挨拶ですはいろんながそれといいんじゃない結構いろんな挨拶
いろんな挨拶するんですけど僕そのなんか特徴的なことがない来て自分じゃないんです
けど僕の言葉音してる人は
おいませんそれはなぜかというと僕に特徴がないからそれはそれでかっこいいな
特徴か欲しいわーやってたんだよこの動画の最後にじゃあなって
[音楽]
じゃんそういうのは問題か水そんなも全然もダメでは声ですよえもっと候補都市やっぱ
でもっとこうなんかやっついなのが欲しいんですけど地熱皆さんお気づきだと思います
けど僕じゃあなぁ結構言ってませんからね最近方飽きちゃったんですよじゃあなぁ普通
すぎて
びっくりした去年はもうエンディング帰って今のインディで満足してるんですけども
特徴的なこと僕の音って工具が説明できないなんて言えばいいんだろう分かります
アイデンティティという形を取ってほしい1件もんだもうちょっと細い顔シーンであっ
はぁっ
もし仮に今僕にあるとしたら多分ちゃんずこんにちははじめ社長ですと
じゃあな
ん
うわぁない米のありそうさあ
やだねぇいや単にいってのダウニー店ですなんと自分で言ったら恥ずかしいですも然り
ですよもし仮に今を考えますよなんじゃないかな
ん
今ねでピンピンピストルだっけんっ
まずやめとこジャッジなものを作る能力には欠けているとずいぶんしておりますよね
打撲こんにちははじめちゃうベストツアーの思考もう1個はなかったんですけどもあの
挨拶決めましょどうやらせたが交流の声なんかやりたいんですけどないんですよ
これちょっと今回は皆様に僕の挨拶を募集すると思います投げちゃうぞ
何卒よろしくお願い致します
コメントだけでもいいんですけどなんかて無理と金を入れられないですこういうあっ
違ういろんな手振りとかの説明を加えてしゃべる内容よかったらコメント欄で帰って
くれると非常にありがたいでございますインパクトがあればいいと思っております
インパクトもインパクトしか求めてないかもしれない合えばかわいい多いが押すんです
ね可愛くなくてもいいやプレゼンもインパクトがあれば僕はそれを採用し
思っておりますので皆さん良ければこの動画のコメ寺に僕の挨拶を考えてください他の
専従ずっ
ああ
結構切実な問題でございます真似することが大事ですよ僕もう元の中
挨拶とかでやってみんなにマネされたイベントで彫ったらみんなも伊勢にピーってやる
みたいな
もうやりたいんですけどスパイダーをいただければございますよかったらこのコメント
でお待ちしております今月中には決めるので僅かまで
1月の僅かなでこのコメント欄で受け付けております動く
こちらにそれで挨拶決めて甘やか素材里ずっと使っていきたいなんですけど1幕今年は
その手で決めた挨拶を1年がやってみようかなと思っておりますでは皆さんのコメント
お待ちしております
ジャン車オー秋田からもやりたくないんですよジャブ
me
[音楽]
バッハ